[Music]
changing so fast the last time I talked
to you and you're this you're becoming
this huge star and you were saying yeah
my roommate and you were revealed that
you had a roommate yeah still which I
thought was cool yeah do you still have
that roommate or is this going to
complicate things now that you're
getting married no no no I actually have
something to confess uh my old roommate
David Tom I uh he is the worst luck on
the entire planet
um and he's convinced that 2012 is the
end of the world so I wanted him to
believe that meteorites were slamming
into her backyard and I did just that
and he's convinced and so you played a
prank on it I played a prank on him I
went and uh me and my buddy Phil went
because this is how do you fake meteor
is hitting the backyard
I don't know how you would do that I
went and bought some actual meteorites
and I dug a giant crater in our backyard
filled it up with dry ice covered it
with dirt and then put the meteorites in
the middle of it and then you know
dumped a bunch of water on it and then I
set off a dry ice bomb in the backyard
and so he was in the bedroom sleeping
this isn't a prank this is an act of
terrorism
elaborate well here's what I did no no I
went to Peru and bought some lava then
got some robots
so I set up this dry ice bomb and uh it
exploded and he runs out of his bedroom
and his boxers like what was that
because literally the uh the house kind
of Shook and I go I don't know the
entire backyard lit up and he ran
outside in his boxers and he sees this
giant crater just boiling and he starts
pulling out you know actually I brought
some uh these rocks he starts pulling
out these rocks do you have the you went
and went where did you seriously get
these you said you went out and bought
meteors yeah there's a there's a
meteorite shop in Santa Monica oh yeah I
like the one in Glendale
the competing meteorites but he started
panicking because he really he was
convinced he believed that these things
were slamming into the Earth and then it
actually made it on uh Fox 11 News well
no it didn't yes yes wait did they know
that it was you and then no no no no no
not at all his girlfriend didn't even
tell him that she was taking the footage
that she shot to the news I was watching
the Giants and 49ers playoff game and
yeah
um and then uh it went a little late so
they can only uh show two clips in the
news and one of them was this wait a
minute you weren't even aware no you're
watching the news now and they cut but
in the news story about the prank you
pull yes I start seeing my foot as I
start seeing my backyard of this giant
crater boiling I'm like what the hell is
that and uh yeah and his girlfriend
never told him that I love that that's
also a small story on the local news
if there was a little time left uh
pieces of of debris are falling under
the Earth and I think we have the story
right now this is the actual news story
this is video that was shot just
Wednesday and it's kind of difficult to
see but that's a big crater and
basically what happened was
um this was in North Hollywood there was
a big boom and the residents there
rushed outside to see what it could be
they found this crater with a rock in
the middle and you see there the water
is roiling it looks as if there's dry
ice in there
all right
there was dry ice in there
I couldn't I couldn't believe it who
also sees like uh rocks Came From Outer
Space hit the ground caused water to
boil and I'm putting my hand in exactly
because I'm like Dave what are you doing
I mean he pulls out this rock it looks
like it has special powers and I'm like
don't touch that and I don't know I mean
it needless to say he's not going to be
your roommate anymore no he's not